c'est un jugement toujours très contesté
khaled rares et nice et un journaliste
dans la tournante qui continue de
rejeter les accusations portées contre
lui
le reporter algérien indépendant
condamné à trois ans de prison ferme
s'est défendu ce mardi lors de son
procès en appel
il affirme je cite n'avoir fait que son
métier durant les manifestations du irak
en algérie depuis le premier jour je
n'ai fait que mon métier de journaliste
je suis là parce que j'ai couvert le
irak en toute indépendance
on peut revoir toutes mes interventions
pour voir s'il ya une atteinte à l'unité
nationale
je relate l effet ce mardi un
rassemblement se tenait devant la cour
d'alger pour réclamer sa libération le
10 août il avait été condamné pour
incitation attroupement non armés et
atteinte à l'unité nationale
journalistes militants et défenseurs des
droits de l'homme dénoncent un verdict
beaucoup trop sévère
aujourd'hui nous sommes des journalistes
rassemblés devant le tribunal de la
capitale parce qu'il est prévu que le
verdict en appel soit rendue nous en
tant que journaliste condamnant
fermement cette décision injuste prise
contre khaled a régné à une peine de 3
ans chose jamais vue auparavant dans le
monde du journalisme algérien c'est une
honte et un grand scandale qu'un
journaliste soit emprisonné car il
n'exerçait que sa profession son travail
et ses devoirs de journalistes
nous ne sommes pas ici seulement pour
nous unir aux frères amis combattants
journalistes et reporters khaled rares
eni
c'est pour le bien de sa liberté khaled
dont je suis le cas au quotidien et à
travers nos échanges est un homme libre
et restera journalistes le journaliste
de 40 ans est aussi devenu le symbole du
combat pour la liberté des médias en
algérie mais également à l'international
à paris journaliste et présentateur télé
se sont rassemblés devant l'ambassade
d'algérie pour soutenir leurs confrères
mais on est là tous ensemble et toutes
ensemble pour rappeler que la place de
khaled n'est pas en prison qu'il est
incarcéré
alors que son dossier est vide qu'il a
tout simplement converse chaque jour au
quotidien les manifestations pacifiques
du snelac et qu'il n'est pas condamné
pour ce qu'il a fait mais pour ce qu'il
est à savoir un symbole un espoir aussi
de liberté liberté d'expression à la
fois de toute une jeunesse mode là de
tout le peuple algérien khaled rariny et
notre correspondant à alger depuis des
années il a été condamné à trois ans de
prison ferme pour avoir exercé son
métier
nous mettons d'ailleurs en ligne tous
les jours ces reportages pour que ceux
qui nous regardent puisse vérifier qu'il
est bien un journaliste et non pas un
militant ou un agitateur comme le
prétend la justice algérienne
de son côté le gouvernement algérien
tente de se justifier en mai dernier le
président d'elcs madjid tebboune
qualifiait khaled rares et ni je cite
d'un formateur pour le compte des
ambassades étrangères
alger lui reproche aussi d'avoir
travaillé sans carte de presse
professionnelle